unanimement les personnes qui étaient
autour de la table ont salué d'abord la
pertinence de ce discours en ce moment à
quelques semaines des élections
européennes devant un parterre de jeunes
étudiants en formation agricole qui peut
être moins que nous notre génération
perçoivent l'importance de la sécurité
alimentaire et d'une production agricole
en europe
alors il faut aujourd'hui conjuguer la
production agricole la sécurité
alimentaire avec la nouvelle donne
climatique et c'est plus compliqué mais
il faut bien mettre à égalité dans ce la
nécessité de conserver des productions
sécurisé et racé et la protection de
l'environnement
il a aussi rappelé l'attachement un
budget agricole et à des dispositifs qui
vont permettre aux exportations rigole
depuis compétitive et plus résiliente a
peur peut rentrer dans le détail sur
quelques manques sur la question de la
régulation la résilience
j'ai insisté au cours du déjeuner en
complément sur la question de l'eau et
de l'irrigation dans un contexte de
changement climatique beaucoup plus de
sécheresse très graves comme celles de
deux mails de 2018 on peut pas gérer
l'eau comment la gérer avant